Sandra or Kerry Washington where the
latest duo to have a virtual chat for
varieties actors on actors at home
series yeah and the actresses and
producers spoke a lot about race and
representation on television with Sandra
revealing that the fact it was appointed
decision not to acknowledge that her
character was in an interracial
relationship on Grey's Anatomy most of
the shows and almost every the things
that I have done have not been Asian
specific purposefully you know like when
we didn't graze for at least the first
ten seasons we would not we would not
talk about race we would not go into
rain and that was perfect that was
purposeful and and whatever it was the
right thing to do when it was you know I
mean there are times where you know
there early seasons like season three
Burke and Christina were getting married
and there were the two mothers you know
the Asian mother and the black mother
I'm like come on there's a lot of story
that we can do here right but they
didn't want to do in [ __ ] for whatever
reason it wasn't that whatever it was it
was what it was and I I kind of think it
was it now my interest is much more in
bringing that story in what I was able
to get from Grey's is to have the
responsibility and the relationship with
the writer to be able to direct where
she's going you know I mean if something
that kind of came up which was like that
is completely wrong
I'm you know I would go toe to toe I you
know I'm I've gone toe to toe is Shonda
and a lot of the writers and which has
been challenging but I think ultimately
for the entire product and our
relationship is like if you are fighting
for the show you're fighting for your
character and you can leave the Eagle
outside people can tell that yeah this
is an interesting one because I mean it
goes it goes both ways because there's
definitely times where you know we'll
race should be part of it like never
there's been discussions of the you know
whether character is gay or something
either you know shouldn't be knowledge
can't they just you know be you know
doing every other job like remember was
the thing with um the character in Star
Trek and in the movie like you know they
met pietà partner but people complaining
you know just doing his job so it's
interesting whether or not certain
things need to be acknowledged I think
it's good in both circumstance I think
sometimes it is good to you know
acknowledge sex orientation and and race
but then yeah and some stories yeah it's
not necessarily they doesn't have to be
a big part of it I don't think I said
that right but someone else can talk you
know it's funny I'm watching Grey's
Anatomy with my kids right now and we're
on to season two so I'm going through it
all there just became a couple and my
first response was yeah put the color
people together why not I was like why
is this happening right now what
couldn't she have been with McDreamy or
McSteamy or whatever his name was and I
was a little bit frustrated to be honest
with the whole situation when I was
watching it so I haven't got to this
point I shouldn't be watching the
wedding scene I haven't got to the point
but it's there is power to storytelling
so if you were to acknowledge the
diversity if you were to acknowledge the
mom and her mom relationship when
they're having the wedding scene I think
that's very powerful it opens up a
conversation it also educates people of
other cultures and other other way
people live and so I think it was a
mistake that they didn't especially if
you're going to put the asian and black
person together why are you doing that
and they should have made that a
storyline in Grey's Anatomy I think they
missed the point of the whole storyline
in itself yeah I mean I see it you know
two ways I feel like you know another
way to help normalize interracial
relationships is not making it a topic
necessarily making it like road you know
you know to white people on TV you know
we don't talk about the fact that
they're two people white people on TV
they're just in a relationship and you
know sometimes not acknowledging that
they're interracial can help normalize
it but at the same time I don't think
that we as a society are evolved enough
to get to the point where we're not
acknowledging it yet you know I don't
tell people are literally like for the
first time ever people are like wow
black people just showed up like black
people feel like they're brand-new
little to the world right now because
everyone is finally acknowledging all
the racism that's happened to one for so
long but I think we're not at a place
yet where we can
kind of not acknowledge it I think we've
got so much more work to put in where
once we start seeing everybody as equal
and we start breaking down you know
systemic racism and all that I think
then we can get to a point where it's
gonna look normal you know
yeah it took a long time we would get to
that point of norm normalcy right they
think you're right yeah it would be
great if we're at that point where we
don't have to acknowledge it but I don't
think at that point when Grey's Anatomy
was happening they should have you know
there's a reason why you did that why
did you do that and I actually would
like the answer to that I wonder if one
day we can find out why did you put them
together as a relationship on Grey's
Anatomy
they also touch about the lgbtq+
community as well at a time that it
wasn't acknowledged so it was
interesting to see they put a lot of
power towards that story but not this
story so I'm interested to know why so
uh yeah I'll tell you when I get to that
scene when they get married in season
three we'll talk about it again and see
how that come frank zappa
I am assuming it's because of yeah they
were trying to normalize it no I think
it's important like Christine saying I
can't agree we either like a couple
don't really female color race doesn't
influence us or me but I think that's a
conversation although blog people are
having now that you know a lot of people
want to say you know I don't see race
like it's okay to see race because it's
obvious that people have different
experiences different life experiences
are treated differently based on their
race so it's okay to acknowledge that
someone else is a different race it's
once you start treating that race
differently then it becomes an issue but
it's okay to acknowledge it's okay to
speak of some people and say I don't see
color but it's okay to see color yeah I
would assume the creator of Grey's
Anatomy
I never say her name right Shan Shan
Shan's yep oh gosh she's so incredible
but you know I'm assuming in creating
the show she wanted to create a show
that was different from what she used to
watch growing up so I'm sure there was a
lot of you know not overly acknowledging
certain things on purpose probably for
her own personal feeling towards the
show because I'm sure for her you know
she
seen so much television that has made
being of color such a big thing or you
know the token black character the token
Asian character or whatever it may be so
it might have been a purposeful effort
on her behalf but I would love to find
out yeah that's good question mm-hmm